Democrats hopes were dashed as former
counsel robert muller disintegrated in
real time on Capitol Hill today we will
examine what he said and more
importantly what he didn't say
then Gallup finds that Americans care
about one issue above all the others as
we head into 2020 we'll analyze what it
means for President Trump and for the
Democrats running against him
finally Colorado State University
publishes an Orwellian inclusive
language guide that reveals the truth
about why the Left loves political
correctness all that and more i'm
michael knowles and this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
first of all let's get one thing
absolutely clear
nobody cares about Robert Muller nobody
cares about the Muller investigation
nobody cares about the Russian collusion
conspiracy nobody cares about any of
that
okay everyone has moved on other than
people on Twitter and partisan Democrats
who were upset that they were unable to
impeach the president who were upset
that the president wasn't a traitor who
was working on behalf of Russia that
doesn't matter what does matter however
is what Robert Muller's testimony today
means for 2020 the investigation itself
is old news we vote we've done it it was
old news before it even began but the
testimony today actually does matter and
the main takeaway is this was an
absolutely devastating day for Democrats
now I couldn't have predicted that I
figured I figured what was gonna happen
is Muller releases his report it
exonerates Trump on colluding with
Russia it refuses to exonerate Trump on
obstruction of justice
so the DOJ finally had to come to that
conclusion and say Trump didn't obstruct
justice they weren't gonna go after him
then Muller has his press conference he
writes his angry letter so the Democrats
at this point think Muller has got some
more fire left in him we maybe we can
bring him out and fill in all the gaps
that we weren't able to get out of the
Muller report so I would have expected
there would be something anything for
the Democrats to grab here
what happened surprised a lot of people
today which was that the guy just
completely collapsed he just fell apart
okay there were there were two moments
that the Democrats got today that
they're gonna be playing over and over
again on the left-wing cable news
channels they are excited for exactly
two moments the first one is when Bob
Muller says that you can indict a former
president report did not conclude that
he did not commit obstruction of justice
is that correct that is correct and what
about total exoneration did you actually
totally exonerate the president no now
in fact your reports expressly states
that it does not exonerate the president
it does okay that that was actually the
second moment but the first woman is
they say that you
can indict a former president that's
what Bob Muller admits can you you can't
go after the president while he's in
office but you can't go but you can go
after the president after he's out of
office this is not a comment on Trump
this is a comment on the office of the
president period this is simply a
procedural answer in legal reality now
okay that's fine if Democrats wanted to
hear that I guess it sort of sounds like
a Muller can go after Trump or they're
gonna go after Trump once he leaves
office the only other thing that
Democrats got was when Muller said he
didn't exonerate President Trump on
obstruction which we already knew so
this was the highlight for Democrats
testimony today President Trump walks
away from this episode the victor and
here's why not even because if not
certainly not nothing that President
Trump did but because Bob Muller looked
weak and confused the high point is
Muller's says I didn't exonerate him
entirely okay you got that we already
knew that from the report but already
from the Muller report President Trump
comes out looking pretty good Muller
didn't totally exonerate him on
obstruction which was bad for Trump but
it did exonerate him on collusion which
is the actual crime in question so
pretty good today made president Trump's
victory cleaner because what it did far
from giving more fodder for partisan
Democrats it actually cast doubt on the
Russia investigation itself on the whole
thing and frankly on Mulder's role in
the whole thing the the biggest loser
today probably was Bob Muller because
the Democrats had pinned all of their
hopes on Muller and and therefore when
he fell the Democrats got her to a
lesser degree Democrats were the big
losers from today Muller wouldn't even
grant Democrats their main talking point
from their own reports so Democrat
representative Hakeem Jeffries
leptin there to say that there is clear
evidence that Donald Trump obstructed
justice after Muller said I didn't
totally exonerate him he comes in he
says that's right he obstructed justice
Muller actually shut him down the
investigation found substantial evidence
that when the President ordered done
began to fire the special counsel
and then lie about it Donald Trump one
committed an obstructive act two
connected to an official proceeding
three did so with corrupt intent those
are the elements of obstruction of
justice this is the United States of
America no one is above the law no one
the President must be held accountable
one way or the other
let me let me just say if I might I
don't subscribe necessarily to your the
way you analyze that I'm not saying it's
out of the ballpark but I'm not
supportive of that analytical charge
thank you thank you thank you for saying
that what I said is complete BS so it
all went downhill from there
for the Russia conspiracy theorists the
Republicans jump in Republican
representative John Ratcliffe asked Bob
Muller about this issue of exonerating
raid not exonerating and he pointed out
that Muller's language in this report is
is bizarre it's bizarre to say I
couldn't totally perfectly conclude that
he didn't commit a crime so I don't
exonerate him and what representative
Ratcliffe asked is is there any other
case that he can recall of the DOJ
choosing not to exonerate because
innocence was not conclusively
determined example other than Donald
Trump where the Justice Department
determined that an investigated person
was not exonerated because their
innocence was not conclusively
determined I cannot but this is unique
okay well you can't
time is short I've got five minutes
let's just leave it it you can't find it
because I'll tell you why it doesn't
exist of course not of course it doesn't
exist now this is all just this setup
because only now do things start to get
really weird and it raises big questions
about Bob Muller himself we'll get to
that in a second but first if you are
not paying off your credit card bills
every month you were almost certainly
paying hundreds if not thousands of
dollars in interest every year
let Lending Club help you out with
Lending Club you can consolidate your
debt or pay off credit cards with one
fixed monthly payment since 2007 Lending
Club has helped millions of people
regain control of their
finances with affordable fixed-rate
personal loans I can speak a little bit
from experience it's not even that I'm
so terrible with money you know I'm
running up crazy debt it's just that I
like most dudes that I know are lazy
when it comes to my finances and I put
it on the credit card and I forget about
it and I don't think about how much
money I am wasting when you just use
those high interest credit cards don't
do it guys take control of your finances
make it really easy
there's no trips to the bank there's no
high interest credit cards you just have
to go to Lending Club comm and you will
save a ton of money tell them about
yourself tell them how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right for
you and if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days this
is my kind of service I don't even want
to walk out my door right into your bank
account
that's why Lending Club is the number
one peer-to-peer lending platform with
over 35 billion dollars in loans issues
stop wasting money it takes two seconds
to get control of your finances and and
start making financial sense go to
Lending Club comm / Knowles Kanter wles
check your eight minutes borrow up to
$40,000 that's Lending Club com /
Knowles Lending Club com / Knowles kena
wles all loans made by one bank member
FDIC Equal Housing lender so you've got
Muller saying I didn't totally exonerate
Trump but I'm not saying that he's
guilty of committing obstruction is
guilty of this crime then things start
to get weird
so Muller just starts stonewalling and
this is particularly with regard to the
infamous steel dossier that steel
dossier you'll remember was the report
that was uncorroborated never proven
totally bogus
in many cases report that this Intel X
intelligence guy Christopher Steele made
almost certainly with Russian
intelligence services and he made it for
fusion GPS which is an opposition
research firm that did work for Clinton
and the Democrats this is central to the
whole Russia conspiracy hoax and Muller
Stonewall's on it here is representative
Steve Chabot asking Muller about fusion
and about Christopher steel when
discussing the
June 2016 Trump Tower meeting you
reference quote the firm that produced
the steel reporting unquote the name of
that firm was fusion GPS is that correct
and your on page 103 103 that's correct
volume 2 when you talk about the the
firm that produced the steel reporting
the name of the firm that produced that
was fusion GPS is that correct I'm not
familiar with that it's not it's not a
trick question right it was fusion GPS
now fusion GPS produced the opposition
research document widened widely known
as the steel dossier and the owner of
fusion GPA was someone named Glenn
Simpson are you familiar with this is
outside my purview okay outside of your
purview that's the whole investigation
the steel dossier on which the entire
thing is predicated is outside of your
purview the steel dossier is the
beginning of the Russia conspiracy the
steel dossier was the predicate for the
spying that took place the spying on
members of the Trump campaign that
started this whole three-year ordeal and
Muller seems like he doesn't know he
seems like he's ignorant of it I mean
you have that line from the congressman
he says okay and this is all part of a
few this was put together by fusion GPS
is that right and Muller looks
bewildered dazed and confused he says
well I I don't not totally and and the
congressman has to lean in and say it's
not a trick question it is fusion GPS
it's in your own report Muller seems
totally ignorant of it so then they go
further they start asking Muller not
just about fusion GPS which is the firm
that put it together but Christopher
steel himself the X British intelligence
analyst who put together the entire
report Muller doesn't seem to know very
much about Christopher steel either can
you state with confidence that the steel
dossier was not part of Russia's
disinformation campaign no I said it in
a
my opening statement I'm the that part
of the building of the case was predated
me and by at least 10 months Paul manna
for its alleged crimes regarding tax
evasion predated you you had no problem
charging them and matter of fact it's
this steel dossier predated the Attorney
General and he didn't have any problem
answering the question when senator
Cornyn asked the Attorney General the
exact question I asked you director the
Attorney General said and I'm quoting no
I can't state that with confidence and
that's one of the areas I'm reviewing
I'm concerned about it and I don't think
it's entirely speculative steel steel go
Christopher I don't I know that name
doesn't ring any Bell does it this was a
great question from Republican
congressman Matt gates unfortunately
gates went on a little bit too long in
his question he should have just gone in
there and got in the clean hit of
because here's what he said he said
let's talk about Christopher steel
Muller says well that predates my
experience in the investigation so I
can't talk about it and Gates has that
great follow-up he says well mana forts
tax problems predate your entrance on
into the investigation you're willing to
talk about that why is it you're willing
to talk about things that make Trump
look bad but you're not willing to talk
about things that make Democrats look
bad and maybe make Trump look pretty
good why it's pretty selective about
what you're willing to talk about and
what you're not willing to talk about it
was a good hit I don't mean to knock
Congressman gates too much but it should
have been a cleaner hit he should have
ended it right there and let Muller
stammer which is what he did for much of
the rest of the the hearing the fact
remains either way Muller totally punted
on steel this is pretty weird behavior
two central figures and organizations in
this Russia investigation fusion GPS put
the dossier together took the Clintons
money took the Democrats money and
Christopher steel the guy who actually
wrote the thing that research that they
put together launches the spying
launches the investigation and Bob
Muller the head investigator the Special
Counsel doesn't seem to know anything
about either of them not even that he's
unwilling to talk about it
that he doesn't seem to steal who'd
fusion GPS who yeah I never heard of her
this is difficult to believe it raises
the question is Muller playing dumb or
does Muller actually know not know
what's going on in his own investigation
how much does Bob Muller know about his
own investigation I guess it could be
either he could be playing dumb because
he doesn't want to put himself in at
risk of committing perjury or he doesn't
want to make himself look too naked ly
political or because when you play dumb
it generally works to your advantage in
politics Bill Clinton has bragged about
this George Bush has bragged about this
playing a little below your mark is very
helpful but I don't know maybe he's not
playing dumb maybe he actually doesn't
really know about these things if that
is the case even if I'm willing to
believe that this raises an a more
troubling question if Bob Muller doesn't
know what's going on in his
investigation who does because this has
been the argument the whole time is that
this investigation is extremely partisan
it's being staffed by nevertrump pers
who hate the president's guts who have
been caught in leaked text messages
saying that they want to undermine the
2016 election and prevent the people
from electing Donald Trump and all these
guys have been caught as part of the
Mulder investigation and the response
the whole time was okay sure they're a
couple bad apples but Bob Muller is a
man beyond reproach he's a former Marine
he is an FBI director under Republicans
you couldn't possibly impune his motives
or his reputation or his competence well
I don't know if he doesn't know anything
about his own investigation then I guess
that kind of takes him off the table
doesn't it if if we don't if he doesn't
know anything about his own
investigation who does Peter struck Andy
McCabe Lisa Paige who knows about it who
was actually running it who actually
wrote this thing if not Muller or is
Muller playing dumb don't think this is
some partisan attack there are a lot of
left wingers who are joining me in this
criticism we'll get to it in just one
second but first I have got to tell you
about one of the coolest products I have
ever seen and that is paint your life if
you want to give an incredible gift you
have got to try paint your life dot-com
I this is a gift that I gave to my
step-brother for whom I was the best man
I gave this to him for his wedding
because it was the coolest gift I could
possibly think of you can have an
original painting made of yourself of
your children of your family members of
some special place you loved of some pet
maybe poor old Fido ain't with us
anymore you can have a nice oil painting
done of him at a price you can afford
and this is key because commissioning
art can be very very expensive but paint
your life calm comes in and gives you an
incredible product it is a true painting
done by hand by a world-class artist
it's not some fake you know just
generated with with smoke and mirrors
it's a real genuine painting makes the
perfect gift for birthdays or weddings
or anniversaries you choose the artist
whose work you most admire you work with
them throughout the process until every
detail is perfect so you're getting
proofs all the time there's no risk at
all if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded this is great for
decor it's an actual work of art it's
such in a world of just cheap
commodities this is a real special gift
I'm already because I was so impressed
with this painter in particular I'm
going to be commissioning another one of
them I just love I can't speak highly
enough of it right now is a limited time
offer you can get 30% off your painting
that is right 30% off you I'm telling
you once I'm not gonna say stop what
you're doing because I want you to
finish my show but then once my show is
over go check this out you are gonna
it's going to blow your mind you'll get
30% off free ship and get the special
offer the way to do it is to text
knowles KO wles to 48 48 48 that is
Kayano wles to 48 48 48 canna wles 2 for
8 for 8 for 8 message and data rates may
apply so is Bob Muller playing dumb or
does Bob Muller really have no idea
what's going on in his investigation if
it's the latter then who ran the thing
who wrote the thing who is behind this
witch hunt don't accuse me of having
some partisan attack here that I'm
carrying water for Republicans or
something people from both sides of the
aisle were
absolutely flummoxed by this performance
today Mike Serna vich you know the
right-wing independent journalist he
suggested that the hearing be adjourned
because it constituted elder abuse
against Bob Muller looking a little long
in the tooth on the other side of the
aisle David Axelrod the chief strategist
for Barack Obama he tweeted out simply
quote this is very very painful even
tweeted out later he said you know this
is this is a very delicate subject but
when Muller testified before Congress
six years ago he was a lot sharper than
he is today
at one point a kid you not at one point
Muller couldn't remember which President
appointed him US attorney in Boston
director Muller I'm disappointed that
some have questioned your motives
throughout this process and I want to
take a moment to remind the American
people of who you are and your exemplary
service to our country you are a marine
you served in Vietnam and earned a
Bronze Star and a Purple Heart
correct correct which President
appointed you to become the United
States attorney from Massachusetts which
Senator which president which President
I think that was President Bush
according to my notes it was President
Ronald Reagan had the honor to do so
under whose it my mistake oh man this is
genuinely you pity the guy I mean he
evokes a lot of sympathy here even from
the beginning he the question was which
president appoint should you US Attorney
he said which senator senators don't
appoint you US Attorney presidents do
that so no which president because I
don't know Bush and no Reagan like it's
not a trick question the same thing with
huge and GPS this isn't a trick question
we're just establishing your credibility
that was a friendly question from a
Democrat really bizarre look he might be
senile he might have been off his meds
or something or he might be playing dumb
either way the most revealing part of
this testimony is that he punted on one
question so you saw a build-up he punts
on Christopher's deal
he punts on fusion GPS oh I don't know
little what what do I know but then he's
asked a very pointed question on how the
investigation got started and people
aren't really covering this but this is
the key to the testimony and it's a
little bit complicated so bear with me
Bob Muller has asked why Joseph Smith's
hood who lied to the FBI was not charged
with a crime if that name Joseph Mifsud
sounds familiar
he matters because he's this Maltese
academic he is a professor he's in
London he's in Paris he's in Malta he's
in Rome and he's clearly got ties to
intelligence agencies some people say
he's tied to Russian intelligence some
people say he's tied to Western
intelligence maybe he's tied to both and
he is the academic who told the Trump
staffer George papadopolis that the
Russians had dirt on Clinton so this
whole episode the whole question of
whether this Russia investigation was a
setup from the very beginning comes down
to this guy Joseph Smith suit how did
George papadopolis the Trump staffer
come to find out that or here rather
whether it's true or not how did he come
to hear that the Russians had dirt on
Hillary Clinton and then how did he come
to pass that information along which was
the trigger that started the
investigation which allowed the Obama
administration to spy on the Trump
campaign how did that happen
Josef Massoud is at the center of this
and Muller refuses to answer the FBI
interviewed Joseph Masood on February
10th 2017 in that interview mr. Mifsud
lied you point this out on page 193
volume 1 Mifsud denied Mifflin also
falsely stated in addition Mifsud
omitted three times he lied to the FBI
yet you didn't charge him with the crime
excuse me I'm sorry did you say 193
volume 1 193 he lied three times he
pointed out in the report
why didn't you charge him with the crime
I can't get into internal deliberations
with regard who would or would not be
our gelato other people from make up
false table s
that's right he charged a lot of other
people for making false statements but
you see Muller just keeps going back to
this I
can't talk about internal deliberations
I can't talk about why I charge somebody
but I didn't charge any but other people
well it's a little weird mr. Muller
because on the one hand you're charging
Mike Flynn for lying you're charging
Papadopoulos you're charging all of
these guys associated with Trump for in
some cases very minor lies but then this
guy this academic Joseph Mifsud who lies
on three occasions to the FBI he doesn't
get charged with a crime why not the
obvious implication is that he has
worked with Western intelligence the
obvious implication is that he's got a
long-standing relationship with the FBI
in the intelligence community and the
question that is being raised is what
was MIFF sooths role in talking to
Papadopoulos did joseph Mifsud this this
cosmopolitan academic who just floats
Flitz around all over the world just
happened to bump into george papadapolis
just happen to say that the russians had
dirt on hillary clinton which just
happened to prompt the events that led
to the spying on the Trump campaign was
that just an accident or was there some
collusion not between Trump and the
Russians but between the Obama
administration and guys like Joseph
Mifsud
that's the question and that's a key
question that has not been answered the
FBI did it did the FBI use Mifsud to
prod Papadopoulos who was working on the
Trump campaign that's a crucial question
and Jim Jordan thankfully does not let
up so he sets up this whole scene then
he asks the question
point-blank what is the relationship
between the intelligence community and
Professor Mitsu page one of the report
July 31st 2016 they open the
investigation based on that piece of
information diplomat tells Papadopoulos
Russians have dirt excuse me capitalist
tells the diplomat Russians have dirt on
Clinton diplomat tells the FBI what I'm
wondering is who told Papadopoulos how'd
he find out I can't get into the
evidentiary file
because you thought about it you gave us
the answer page 192 of the report you
tell us who told him
Joseph nipson Joseph MIPS is a guy who
told Papadopoulos the mysterious
professor who lives in Rome in London
works at teach in two different
universities this is the guy who told
Papadopoulos he's the guy who starts at
all and when the FBI interviews him he
lies three times and yet you don't
charge him with a crime you charge Rick
gates for false statements she charged
Paul Manafort for false statements you
charged Michael Cohen with false
statements he charged Michael Flynn a
three-star general with false statements
but the guy who puts the country through
this whole saga starts it all for three
years we've lived this now he lies and
you guys don't charge him and I'm
curious as to why absolutely stellar
performance from Jim Jordan here and he
nails him just look at Mulder's reaction
when he says I want to get down to myth
suit I want to I want to know who told
Papadopoulos on the Trump campaign that
the Russians had dirt on Hillary and you
see Muller won't let him get the words
out of his mouth Muller jumps in I can't
talk about that ayah this is nothing
that I can talk about and Jordan's got
him right where he wants him because he
says of course you can talk about that
you already did it's in your report or
is it your report it's in the Muller
report I don't know who wrote it clearly
you don't have much of a recollection of
it but you already admitted that it was
Mifsud
who told him again raises the question
does Muller know about his own report is
he playing dumb
he clearly looks uncomfortable here he
clearly looks nervous
he's jumping and saying we can't talk
about how this whole thing started the
one common thread through all this
testimony is this guy will not talk
about how this investigation got started
I wonder why then Jim Jordan goes in for
the kill we'll get to that in a second
we'll also get to the number-one issue
for Americans as we look down to 2020
according to Gallup polling and the
Orwellian inclusive language guide from
Colorado State University but first I've
got to say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube and I got to
tell you guys
today 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific our
latest episode of the conversation will
be featuring the the great Supreme Lord
of the multiverse Andrew Clavin you will
be answering your questions live so make
them good as always the episode is free
to watch on YouTube and Facebook only
subscribers can ask the questions
subscribe today at the daily wire get
your questions answered by drew Clavin
at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific and
join the conversation I also have to
give a little plug to our buddy bill
whittles podcast Bill Whittle you know
him you've seen him before he has an
incredible podcast out on the Apollo 11
mission the moon landing the other day I
put out a video talking to people about
all the various theories of how we
didn't actually go to the moon between 6
and 20 percent of Americans don't think
we ever went to the moon because there's
a lot of misinformation floating out
there check out this podcast it is
informative it is historical but it's
also incredibly inspiring because this
month marks the 50th anniversary since
we first put a man on the moon this new
podcast by esoteric radio theater is
called Apollo 11 what we saw it shot
immediately to number 3 on iTunes Apple
podcasts I'd stayed there in the top 10
for a week and it's getting great
reviews almost 1 million people have
listened to the podcast or watched on
YouTube it's really just excellent don't
tell bill that I was so kind about it
but it is really really good and Bill is
he's an author he's a pilot
he's a space enthusiast he takes you on
the journey of what it took to get to
the moon what happens when we got there
and how we almost didn't get there at
all all four episodes are available
right now so you can binge it head over
to Apple podcasts or wherever you listen
to podcasts subscribe today to Apollo 11
what we saw well you're there please
make sure that you subscribe to our show
the Michael NOLA
really helps us out when you subscribe
so please do that then you'll never miss
even one syllable one pearl of wisdom
you can watch all of that you can also
watch the podcast episodes of Apollo 11
all over YouTube at the esoteric radio
theater YouTube channel head over there
right now head over to daily wire comm
we'll be right back with a lot more
so Jordan totally demolishes Muller he
he asks him to question Muller jumps he
doesn't want to answer the question he
says he can't talk about it
Jordan says of course you can talk about
it you wrote it in the report that you
apparently didn't even read then Jordan
goes in for the kill
here he is when the FBI interviewed him
in February FBI interviews him in
February when the special counsels
office interviewed Mifsud did he lie to
you get into that did you interview
Mifsud get into that his Mifsud Western
intelligence of Russian intelligence
can't get into that a lot of things you
can't get into what's interesting you
can charge 13 Russians no one's ever
heard of no one's ever seen no one's
ever gonna hear of him no one's ever
gonna see him you can charge them you
can charge all kinds of people who are
around the president with false
statements but the guy who launches
every the guy who puts this whole story
in motion you can't charge him I think
that's amazing sir tonight I'm not
certain I agree with your
characterization well I'm reading from
your report
ouch that's pretty bad I'm not sure I
agree with your characterizations
they're not my characterizations mr.
Muller they're yours I'm reading from
your report this is brutal for the
Democrats on Capitol Hill who brought
Muller up to testify it shows us
something that I had suspected but I
wouldn't put money on which is that the
Democrats best shot here was to just run
on the Muller port and keep Muller
himself quiet just take the report you
can spin the report however you want and
and just keep my lord quiet but the
Democrats couldn't do that because they
were disappointed with the report
because it more or less exonerated the
president you know a little bit on the
edges or obstruction or some Tweety sent
so they could have used that they could
have taken those little bits and tried
to say that Trump was guilty of all
these things instead they wanted more
they thought that they would get more by
having Mulder testify and there are more
unanswered questions than answers in
their report namely how did the
investigation
that question reflects very poorly on
Democrats and it undermines whatever
political wind Democrats had with the
report I mean they did have a little bit
of a win Trump did get dinged in this
report he was not fully exonerated by
Bob Muller on obstruction they could
have had it but they got ready now with
this testimony it really is making the
whole Russia report and the whole
investigation seem illegitimate the only
hope for Democrats in all of this is
that no one cares about Muller or Russia
or collusion or any of it they've all
moved on the bad news for Democrats
right now is one they've lost even even
a minor talking point but to Gallup
polling shows that more people than ever
are concerned about illegal immigration
which is a terrible issue for them and a
great issue for Republicans and
president Trump Gallup polling shows
more Americans than ever ever before are
concerned about illegal immigration and
it's the top issue in the country 27% of
Americans identify immigration as the
most important u.s. problem this
surpasses the previous high of 23
percent in June to put that in
perspective because it seems like kind
of a low number you think the top issue
would have 75% or 80% no people are very
fragmented about what issues they care
about very few issues since 2001 since
they've really started this polling have
ever eclipsed 27 percent so this is a
top issue even historically now
immigration is the biggest concern the
next biggest problem is government /
leadership and this isn't just it's a
problem for Trump but it's not only a
problem for Trump this has been the case
since the second Obama term as well that
so you got 27% immigration 23%
government leadership the next-highest
issues are racism race relations at 7%
and health care at 7% so way way below a
quarter or a third what the number one
and number two issues are now this is a
double-edged sword for trumpet this
actually isn't just all good news for
Trump because the good news is he owns
the illegal immigration issue and this
will help him
because he owns it except he hasn't
built the wall FoxNews confirmed that
CBP report the other day Customs and
Border Protection came out and said
President Trump has not built one mile
of new border wall since he was elected
president and you heard some people
pushing back the people who will just
defend the president regardless of
what's actually happening they were
pushing back and saying no there is wall
there there's new wall Fox News
confirmed the report so unless they have
information unless someone has
information that I don't right now it
looks like he hasn't built any new
border wall look I get that it's hard
again it's hard from an environmental
perspective it's hard from the Zoning
perspective obviously it's hard from a
bureaucratic and a Democrat obstruction
perspective but if he hasn't built the
wall he doesn't look great on that issue
it's also bad for President Trump
because he's the incumbent which now
makes him the object of everybody's ire
if you believe that the second biggest
issue according to Americans is
government and leadership so there is a
simple fix for this it'll help him on
the top biggest issue and it'll help him
on the second biggest issue build the
wall easy or if you can't build the wall
cuz it's too hard and at least propose a
plan to get the wall built a clear plan
so that we don't need to just keep
believing promises or if you can't do
that because I understand very difficult
to do that
short of that start deporting criminal
aliens and start really deporting we
were told last week that the US would be
deporting millions of criminal aliens
remember that on Sunday there were all
these protests all over the country no
don't do it there's a terrorist attack
at a nice facility and do you know how
many people we arrested 18 not 18
million not 18,000 18 people there were
orders of magnitude more protesters
protesting the alleged mass arrests and
deportation then there were people who
actually got arrested to be deported
even forget President let's say you
can't build a wall let's say you can't
get a plan to build a wall even
deporting lots and
lots of criminal aliens publicly would
help him on the subject of illegal
immigration and on the subject of
government and leadership it would show
leadership it would show progress on the
top issue president Trump had really
good instincts in 2016 to focus on
immigration it wasn't just him a few
other people got this actually daily
wire god-king Jeremy boring and our
senior producer Jonathan hey he
understood both of them understood that
immigration was going to be the big
issue back in 2014 they made a movie of
movie called the Arroyo all about
illegal immigration because they saw
coming down the pike this was going to
be a big problem
president Trump saw that in 2015 when he
came down that elevator at Trump Tower
he made that in many ways the defining
issue of his campaign good moves smart
ever since then the issue has moved even
more in Trump's favor great all the
better
but you got to show some leadership on
him also import I mean time's running
out by the way what are what is it or
I'm already in the end of july 2019
presidential campaigns move fast so
there there needs to be action on that
if President Trump is going to
capitalize on on this new Gallup polling
also important to remember though that
people don't only care about political
issues they might not even primarily
care about political issues they also
care about cultural issues when I ask
people why they voted for president
Trump some of them will say immigration
I want to get rid of illegals I want to
border control some of them will say the
economy I want jobs the Obama economy
was awful many more people will say it
wasn't that that it was because they
want to smash political correctness that
they feel that political correctness is
oppressive it's damaging them and
they're done with it and we are now
seeing political correctness to the
extreme out of Colorado State University
this story was reported last October and
now there's a final version of it coming
out now Colorado State University has
published something called an inclusive
language guide how it were well e'en is
that it was from the inclusive language
committee or something it's hosted on
the women and gender
collaborative website I know you've got
that in your bookmark so you know make
sure make sure to go check it out I read
through this this guide I counted 131
words that you're not allowed to say in
the original draft of this two of the
words were American and America this is
at a public state funded American
University
they said America is offensive and
American is offensive if they find it so
offensive maybe they shouldn't take any
taxpayer funding from America maybe they
shouldn't take government subsidized and
guaranteed loans from America now
they're not willing to do that
now they fortunately there was such a
backlash to that in October they took
that out of the final version but there
are a lot of other crazy things in this
guy I mean obviously we don't have time
for 131 but here's an example listen to
just this logic they say the word
colored to refer to black people is
offensive fair enough yeah people
haven't used that word in a while they
say colored is a highly offensive racial
slur that was often used during
segregation to separate people of color
wait what color color color colored is
bad color is good and if you use
anything else that's bad I think that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense does
it but it's just a it's a euphemism
cycle you had colored that was the that
was the term that everyone was supposed
to use then that fell out of favor and
it became black
then it became african-american then it
went back to black again now it's people
of color which is exactly the same as
saying colored people accept if you say
colored people you're a racial bigot and
if you say people of color you're super
woke for now obviously it's going to
change another phrase that you're not
allowed to say is hip-hip-hooray
that's this is true is they said because
hip-hip-hooray developed from the german
hep hep which they write was a harmless
adorable call shepherds would use when
herding their sheep yeah it seems like
there's no problem right no but they go
on but during the Holocaust German
citizens started using it as a rallying
cry when they would hunt down Jewish
citizens living in the ghettos so if you
use the phrase hip-hip-hooray
hip-hip-hooray if you use that you are a
Nazi according to Colorado State
University they say you're not allowed
to use the expression a long time no see
because that's offensive to Native
Americans how I have no idea they say
that you're not allowed to say no can do
hey Michael can you help me out no can
do that apparently is offensive to
Chinese people again why couldn't
possibly tell you what's wilder though
than all of this what you can say what
you can't say the innocuous expressions
that now I guess are evil and bigoted
what's more interesting than that is how
woke expressions fall out of fashion and
are quickly deemed hateful one example
of this is they say you're no longer
allowed to say homosexual
I thought homosexual was the totally
clinical PC term no they say you're not
allowed to say homosexual but you can
say and what you should say is a gay
okay lesbian okay
bisexual all right pansexual whatever or
queer do you remember like five minutes
ago
when we were told that queer is the new
n-word that queer is a horrible racial
slur which is why that little twit
Carlos massa that little bigoted leftist
at voxcom tried to get steven crowder
and a lot of other conservatives kicked
off of youtube would you remember that
queer because queer is the n-word I went
on a television show and when they use
the word queer when it was used in a
video they bleeped it out because we
were now told queer is the new n-word
except then we're told from Colorado
State actually queer is the right word
and homosexual is the wrong word so if
Crowder had said homosexual in his
podcast or on his show they'd go after
him for that and then if he says it's
queer they're gonna go after him for
that and you're damned if you do and
you're damned if you don't what it shows
what all of this shows these language
guides are not about helping an
aggrieved class obviously not they we
were talking about this yesterday on the
show they the left moves past their
aggrieved classes and ditches them as
soon as it becomes politically useful
they used to prattle on about women's
and feminism now they ditch all those
women for the transgender so-called
community now they make now they force
women out of business if they won't wax
the genitals of grown men wearing a
dress now they won't let girls win high
school scholarships to college because
they force them to compete against men
in women's sports so that's over they
always ditch those groups it's also not
about civility it's not about making a
nicer community though the left is this
vindictive and and scolding as any when
it comes to these words it's not about
charity or civility it's not even about
the particular words because the words
change all the time what it's about is
shutting you up what it's about is
forcing you to check in with the
committee check in with your overlords
at Colorado State or Twitter or YouTube
or wherever before you say anything
because it's not about the words it's
about the opinions that you're
expressing this was all summed up in it
Alice and wonderland
excuse me Alice in Wonderland has this
scene in it where Alice is talking to
Humpty Dumpty and Humpty Dumpty says to
Alice when I use a word it means just
what I choose it to mean neither more
nor less and Alice says the question is
whether you can make words mean so many
different things and Humpty Dumpty knows
better he says the question is which is
to be master that is all we've talked
about it before and you see it again
clear as day out of Colorado State the
left would master our culture by
constantly changing and perverting the
meaning of words and the way that
conservatives can master the culture is
by using words correctly using words to
mean what they mean when the left can't
change the meaning of words they totally
obfuscate I don't know I couldn't say I
don't what does it mean how do we know
you saw Bob Muller doing it all day
today we need to insist on using precise
language we need to insist on asking
precise questions in the vague haziness
of innuendo and emotion
smears and slander the left will win but
in the precision of language and the
precision of questions and the precision
of what is the truth
that's conservatives path forward in the
short run when we insist on that it
hurts us we might get expelled from
Colorado State we might be have
milkshakes thrown at us on the street
we might get squirted by weird super
soakers in Missouri and ruin my nice
suit but in the long run that is the way
that we will win all right that's our
show I had a great time today speaking
to TP USA here in Washington DC I'm
going to be doing a number of other
media appearances so you can check them
out while I'm here in DC and then I'll
be speaking for the young America's
Foundation next week for their
conference and then I'll finally be back
in la-la land in the meantime get your
mailbag questions in for tomorrow I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 hey guys
over on the Matt Walsh show today as we
all suffer through another robert muller
news cycle i'd like to turn our
attention back to the story of Erika
Thomas she claimed to remember that she
was verbally assaulted by a racist white
man at the grocery store well the police
report is out and it's not good for her
and I think when a race hoax is exposed
we should talk about it rather than just
move on as the media wants us to do also
we're going to talk about a an actress
who came out as pansexual even though
the term pansexual has no meaning and
also forever21
unintentionally came up with the most
hilarious marketing gimmick of all time
and we'll talk about that also over on
the Matt wall show